قالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي اجتمع بالسفير الامريكي
لدى اسرائيل واطلعه على سير العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الجاريه في مخيم
جنين كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما مضامين ودلالات احاطه
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي السفير الامريكي
بمجريات العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
جنين كيف يبدو الموقف الامريكي من العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في جنين والى ماذا
قد تتطور الاوضاع الامنيه والسياسيه في
المنطقه اود ان اعبر عن امتنان الحار
للدعم المستمر الامريكي الاسرائيلي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت
حليفا الذي لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه
الدعم الامريكي من العام 1948 للكيان
الاسرائيلي حتى منتصف العام الماضي الدعم
المالي والعسكري تجاوز 130 مليار تشكل ما
نسبته 55% من الدعم العالمي للكيان
الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
ليس لدينا تاكيد بان الولايات المتحده
وافقت على هذه العمليه ولكن اذا كان هناك
نوع من الموافقه فهي مرتبطه
بفهم
كما تقول اسرائيل عن طبيعه هذه العمليه
يشيرون ويقدمون معلومات يعني صعبه تجبر
الامريكيين على القبول بالعمل العسكري
الاسرائيلي لان الاسرائيلي رضيت امريكا او
لم ترضى فانه ذاهب الى عمليات يعني جراحيه
صغيره اداره
بايدن تفعل كلما يمكنها ان تفعله لي
الحد من
الطريقه التي تقوم بها اسرائيل بهذه
العمليه حتى يكون هناك اقل عدد من الخسائر
من الجانبين عمليا ما يجري يعني رغم ان
هناك خلافات في العلن بين الاداره
الامريكيه برئاسه بايدن وحكومه نتنياهو
الا ان ما يحكم هذه العلاقات ليست ليس
الرؤساء بقدر ما يحكمها المؤسسات الرسميه
فان الاسرائيليين يقولون
انها تعني اهدافا محدده
وسريعه للتعامل مع ذلك
التهديد العسكري انا ذاك
ستكون اذا لا تثير الكثير من القلق
الطريقه التي قدمت بها اسرائيل هذه
العمليه اذا كانت هادفه ومركزه وسريعه
للدخول التعامل مع المسائل الاسلحه ثم
الخروج
[موسيقى]
الكيان الاسرائيلي باستمرار يعول على
مواقف الادارات الامريكيه المتعاقبه لانه
يريد من الادارات الامريكيه او
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه توفير غطاء سياسي
ودبلوماسي لجرائمها ودعملها العسكري في
الاراضي الفلسطيني او في حتى الدول
العربيه المحيطه المتحده لا تريد ان ترى
اي مواجهات واي مظاهر عنف واي خساره
لارواح الفلسطينيين الادارات الامريكيه
عمليا يعني الجمهوريين هم يوافقوا على
استهداف الفلسطيني دون طقوس ودون البسمله
الادارات الديمقراطيه توافق على الاستهداف
الفلسطيني والحقوق الفلسطينيه بعد ان
يقراوا البسمله ويقيموا لنا طقوسا تليق
بدفننا ودفن قضيتنا الفلسطينيه الولايات
المتحده لا مصلحه لها في ان ترى
الاسرائيليين يقتلون الفلسطينيين ولا رؤيه
معاناه الفلسطينيين يعني دار الامريكيه
ومعها القاره العجوز الاوروبيه يعني طوال
فتره نشوء اسرائيل الى اللحظه هي التي
اوقفت اسرائيل على قدميها واعتبرت الحبل
السري للكيان الاسرائيلي بامدادها بالمال
والقوه والعتاد والسلاح لطالما قلت بان
اسرائيل لا حليف افضل لها من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وانا اقول لكم الان بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا حليفه افضل
لها من اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
ان
سيخرج يحد من اي خسائر في الارواح ينبغي
على اسرائيل
باسرع وقت ممكن فان امكانيه
تصعيد من
بمشاركه الجهاد او الحماس في غزه او حزب
الله من لبنان هذا اخر ما تريده الولايات
المتحده عمليا الاداره الامريكيه تفضل عمل
سريع في الضفه الغربيه دون ان يتاثر ذلك
ودون ان تمتد الاحداث الى ساحات الضفه
الغربيه الاخرى وهي مخاوف عبر عنها
الشابات كبار في الجيش الاسرائيلي
وهنا ناتي الى ايران
لان الاتهامات الاسرائيليه قد تكون
مشتركه مع الامريكيين تدعم وتمول
محاوله تسليح الضفه الغربيه المراقب
الامريكي هو يشارك في الجريمه ويشارك في
الدم ويشارك بالقتل وقبل ان يتحدث السيد
ادوارد عن السلاح الايراني في المنطقه
لابد له ان يعلم ان السلاح الامريكي هو
موزع على يعني على غلات المستوطنين وما
يهتم به ان يكون الوضع مستقرا قدر الامكان
بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين